[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
the average two-year fixed rate mortgage
Rises to more than six percent
lately the secure storm is set on though
his plans to make the UK a clean energy
superpower
the chief executive of Vodafone UK will
be telling me why he wants to merge with
rival 3.
also ahead why the north of England is
becoming increasingly attractive to
overseas investors
and Morrisons becomes the latest grocery
chain to push through big price cuts
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well before we get to
our guests this morning we start with
some breaking news on mortgage rates
during the last hour the average
two-year fixed rate deal has risen above
six percent that will mean higher bills
for anyone looking to remortgage their
home possibly hundreds of pounds more
every month
well the average residential two-year
fixed-rate deal Rose from 5.98 on Friday
to 6.01 today while the average
five-year fixed rate increased from 5.62
to 5.67 there are 240 fewer Residential
Mortgage products on the market today
dropping from 9 200 920
4923 on Friday to four thousand six
thousand and 183 this morning the
average buy to let two year fixed rate
deal also increased from 6.21 on Friday
to 6.3 percent today while the average
five-year fixed rate deal increased from
6.17 to 6.23 earlier the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak ruled out government help
for households struggling with their
mortgages
yeah I know the anxiety that people will
have about mortgage rate that's why the
first priority I set out at the
beginning of the year was to halve
inflation because that's the best and
most important way that we can keep
costs and interest rates down for people
we've got a clear plan to do that it is
delivering we need to stick to the plan
but there are people now there there is
also support available for people we
have the mortgage guarantee scheme for
first-time buyers and we have the
support for mortgage interest scheme
which is there to help people as well
now Vodafone last week announced plans
to merge with three UK in what would be
the biggest reshaping of the mobile
telephony market in more than a decade
the third and fourth largest operators
in the sector would become the biggest
player by getting together leapfrogging
EE and Virgin Media O2 it would have
nearly 28 million customers and be worth
at least 16 and a half billion pounds
but it faces a lengthy investigation by
both the competition markets Authority
and will require approval under the UK
National Security and investment act
joining me now very pleased to say is
Ahmed Assam he's the chief executive of
Vodafone UK oh my very good to see you
this morning before we get on to the the
rationale and so forth I just want to
ask you about the terms of the deal
because this is envisaged us you owning
uh 51 and three shareholders 49 yeah
your UK sales are getting on for twice
there's and your profits as well so uh
I'm the CEO for Vodafone UK as you know
so I'm I'm not here to speak on behalf
of Vodafone group however the proposed
deal would be 51 uh Vodafone group and
49 uh uh on the three side so uh it's
clearly a deal that's uh creates a lot
of value for both shareholders but I
just can't understand why given new so
much bigger a company you only get 51 of
the uh the merged entity I think the
focus should really be on what this deal
brings to the uh UK market and brings
both value to to both shareholders uh
clearly it's a 51 Vodafone group so
there is uh control and and management
coming from this side but it's a
creative for both for both shareholders
so tell me about the rationale behind
the deal so there's uh we believe it's a
very it's a it's a very good opportunity
for the UK in general we believe the
deal is very good for customers in the
UK because because this creates a much
better Network a much bigger Network a
much reliable Network that will be
available from day one for UK consumers
both both Vodafone entries consumers
will benefit from a wider bigger Network
it's happening to be to merge with a
competitor to become more reliable in
your words so today we have a kind of an
inefficient model in terms of deploying
our investment we're all building maybe
in the key areas and with bringing this
together it will become more of an
efficient investment where we can focus
more on covering the length and breadth
of the UK rather than only focusing on
the key spots in the UK so it becomes a
much more efficient investment the
opportunity for customers to get faster
Network everybody wants more data data
has grown over the past five years by
400 percent and it will continue to rise
by 40 every year so the need for high
higher speeds 5G is cannot be more than
what we have today and this accelerates
the opportunity for this it also
accelerates investment as the plan the
proposed plan is about investing 11
billion over the next uh 10 years this
amount of investment will not only build
a world-class 5G Standalone network but
will also accelerate investment in the
UK will accelerate employment in the UK
and and then maybe last but not least is
from a competition perspective we
believe in a market that's competitive
uh and to deliver on this we need to the
third and fourth players they come
together they properly challenge the two
leading players uh in the market and we
get more of a competitive environment
with more choice for consumers and
businesses and the reason for this
increased investment as a merged
entities because at the moment the pair
of you are not covering your cost of
capital correct so I I think it's it's
been uh well recognized and we've been
quite uh honest and and and and and and
straightforward with it I think the rate
of return in our industry today is is a
challenge uh uh the third and fourth
player we're we're not making returns
that would go above our cost of capital
uh three has been uh cash flow negative
for the past three years so it's not a
sustainable position for us to really
accelerate investment going forward uh
the case that we're bringing together
with this proposed merger would clearly
make investment more efficient as we
deploy where it's needed so I think the
focus should be should be on how we
bring the investment to deliver the best
service for consumers the best service
for businesses and deliver on the
government's Wireless infrastructure
strategy of covering more than 99
percent of the UK with 5G Standalone
which has huge economic value not only
for consumers but also for businesses
now the union is flagging concerns about
Job losses what do you say to them
so uh it's it's very early today to talk
about Job losses but clearly this case
is about investment and with investment
there will be a direct and indirect
benefit from employment clearly we might
get uh provided we get clearance on the
deal and we get to merge companies you
might have some uh roles that might be
impacted and this would go through
proper consultation and uh proper uh uh
uh process but also there is a lot of
room for reskaling there is a lot of
room to to to reinvest in the network
and deploy resources where it can add
value now obviously there's this issue
of the National Security and investment
act as well this is because three UK is
owned by the Hong kong-based company is
that going to be an issue in your view
in my in my opinion we take security uh
procedures very seriously
and as a business that's regulated and
managed by the Telecom security
regulation in the UK and also we respect
customer privacy we take this very
seriously I can tell you that within our
business only customer vetted teams
would have access to secure details so
in some cases not even myself or my
group CEO would have access to such
information both businesses today are
operating in the UK both businesses are
subject to the same regulation we will
need to go through the National Security
process as as we go through it but we're
quite confident that we have a strong
case and we have strong compliance when
it comes to security Now this will take
the market from four players to three
are you expecting a lengthy competition
investigation
so I cannot speak on behalf of the com
the CMA on this front but I have to say
we need to look to the market in a
realistic way uh what this deal is
proposing and what it's bringing is
really a third big Challenger to add to
the competition of the two big markets
the two big companies in in the market
so it's really we need to see it as it's
not four to three it's actually two to
three but then we also need to remember
then around one in four customers in the
UK are buying mobile connectivity from
operators and providers who don't own
their own network so you have the likes
of some of our competitors within the
mobile virtual space and one in four
customers would go there so the market
is quite competitive today and will
remain competitive what this deal brings
is it actually elevates the quality of
the network it brings a third strong
Challenger in the market for even our or
possible Partners within uh providers
who do not own their Network to have
access to another third competitive
Network all right we have to leave there
really busy time for you this so we do
appreciate you joining us today thank
you very much Ian pleasure being here
breaking news to bring you just want to
bring you the latest pictures from
Moscow where the Russian opposition
leader Alexei navalny is appearing at
the start of another trial this is one
that could keep him behind bars for
decades we'll have more reaction to that
throughout the morning here on Sky News
some other business news stories for you
now and the supermarket Shane Morrison's
announced today it is cutting the price
of 47 Lines by at least a quarter the
price Cuts in items including beef mitts
ham tomatoes and spinach will cost it 26
million pounds over the next eight weeks
well the move from the UK's fifth
largest grocery chain is the latest
indication that food price inflation is
beginning to moderate the market leader
Tesco said on Friday it was confident it
was past the peak in inflation while
Sainsbury's Asda and waitrose have all
announced price cutting initiatives in
the last seven days
the bottling company Coca-Cola HBC is
buying the Finlandia Vodka brand from
the Jack Daniels distiller Brown Foreman
for 220 million US Dollars Coca-Cola HBC
which bottles and sells Coca-Cola's
products in nine countries including
Italy Greece and Ireland said ownership
of the Finlandia brand would and then
enhance its premium Spirits credentials
it has been Distributing Finlandia which
first launched in 1970 for the last 17
years the brand sold 2.7 million nine
liter cases last year more than 60
percent of which was in markets served
by Coca-Cola HBC
the Australian mining giant fought his
new mineral Metals said this morning
it's expanding its battery and electric
power chain production operations in the
UK Fortescue future Industries the
company's green power arms at the state
of the art facility in Banbury and
Oxfordshire would create more than 120
jobs the companies already in the
process of opening an electric vehicle
battery Factory at nearby kidlington
with the creation of several hundred
jobs
and Church of England clergy have for
the first time in their history
submitted a formal request for a pay
rise the United Union which claims to
represent more than 2 000 clergy and lay
officers in the Church of England said
this morning it had submitted a claim
for an increase in the stipend that
clergy received of nine and a half
percent to be paid from April next year
under the Union's claim the clergy's
minimum National stipend would rise from
26 795 pounds a year at present to 29
340 pounds
now overseas businesses appear
increasingly to be focusing on the north
of England and Wales when they consider
investing in the UK and it's one of the
main conclusions of a piece of analysis
by ey into foreign direct investments
into the UK during the last couple of
years will the Business Services Group
found that while the number of foreign
direct investment projects fell by six
percent in 2022 that was largely due to
Big declines in London and the southeast
of England there was a 33 rise in the
north to east of England a 27.5 rise in
Yorkshire and a 23 rise in the east
Midlands which joining me now is UK the
UK Chief Economist at ey Peter Arnold
Peter good to see you again um why is
the north of England attracting more FDI
projects well as you as you flagged we
have seen quite a big rise in
investments into the north of England
this year and I think that there's a few
things here I think leveling up does
appear to be as a concept as a
government policy does appear to be
cutting through with foreign investors
so when we ask investors what policy
priorities they think the government
should adopt leveling up actually came
comes first so I think there is that
awareness and actually a desire for
foreign investors to support that agenda
and then when we look at the kind of
sectorial composition of of the north we
see actually there's some real
advantages there that are attracting
that type of investment so we see
digital investment in the north has held
up better than in London perhaps uh
digital companies are looking to expand
their footprint across the UK but have
also seen a strong performance in
manufacturing and a strong performance
in projects associated with renewable
energy and Utilities in the Northeast in
particular so I think that that Net Zero
agenda the leveling up agenda the
combination of those two really
beginning to drive investment in the
north so it's the type of investment
project that appears to be driving this
yes what we're seeing is um larger
manufacturing projects that bring a lot
of value to to the regions as well they
tend to deliver more jobs than perhaps a
sales and marketing investment and and
often in that that Net Zero in the
energy transition space so we're seeing
offshore wind Investments investments in
EVS in carbon capture utilization and
storage and then hydrogen so I think
that's that is a real element of what's
driving that Northern success story
despite that London is still top of the
charts in terms of the overall number of
projects yes I mean absolutely London
remains if you like the engine of the UK
economy it attracted almost 300 projects
this year and and yes they were down but
it's still the number one destination in
the UK in terms of projects recorded
investors still say it's their preferred
location and actually London on its own
is the sort of the fifth most important
destination for FDI across the whole of
Europe behind only
um four countries so it still is really
really attractive but but clearly no
room for complacency and I think this
year's figures you know policy makers
will have to think a little bit about
why why numbers are falling yeah that's
a good point you make there what about
Wales I mean that's all the biggest
increase of in growth of projects anyway
is that just because it's coming off
quite a low base well I think Wales has
probably um and I don't want to accept
upset anybody it's probably
underperformed for the last few years
and it does feel they had a good good
performance this year projects up to 31
up from 17 last year so a quite quite a
strong performance for Wales and and
then perhaps there is you know for after
years of underperformance maybe that
there's now opportunity I think for
Wales to also get a bit of momentum in
foreign investment and what's really
interesting is that there are a number
of cities that stand out for doing
especially well in terms of attracting
investment I mean Manchester is one
Edinburgh is another
yes and so um what they have done really
very well is been able to particularly
Manchester has crafted an identity and a
sort of sense of vision and drive for
the for the region Manchester has a very
clear offer now to investors a lot of
its success is built around digital
creative and Professional Services in
the Manchester City Center but also we
know globally it has a global brand
associated with the football team and a
number of other areas so I think that
that's what teams people teams of course
apologies you know that is very clearly
Manchester's International offer and I
think Edinburgh and indeed Scotland as a
whole is also does very well in that
regard it has a clear offer to investors
and the key cities in Scotland Edinburgh
Glasgow Aberdeen has three cities in the
top five and very clear offers again
around Scotland's traditional strengths
in financial services in oil and gas now
in the renewable energy and also in
digital technology so it's that clear
sense of offer we've built a clear
opportunity for investors to come and
invest and that's what Manchester
Edinburgh and some of the more
successful areas have done all right
Peter got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you very much
thank you thank you
still to come here on your King live
we're going to have a look at how Global
markets are doing this Monday morning
don't go away
[Music]
I'm Greg Milam and I'm Sky's Chief north
of England correspondent
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
thank you
[Music]
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit Harry Dunn is 42 year old
am circulus just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far this
is what they're up against is
back-breaking work
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid change seems
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
welcome back our late payments by larger
suppliers has for many years been a bug
bearer of small business and remains so
despite moves by the government to name
and shame persistent offenders well now
the Federation of small businesses is
hoping to turn up the heat on late
payers by appealing to their
shareholders to hold them to account
joining me now is Martin mctaggy's
National chair of the Federation of
small businesses Martin welcome to you
first of all reminds everyone what a
problem this is how problematic it is
it's a massive problem for most small
businesses in the UK they're having to
double their working capital just to be
able to fund late payments and that
means that's all wasted investment
opportunity so we think it should be top
of the list as far as government's
concerned and you also think that for
shareholders this is an ESG
environmental social and governance
issue it certainly is I mean when you
talk to a lot of investors they
understand the E component and the g
component the thing that gets missed a
lot of the time is the S component now
what we are saying is if you want a
sustainable business something that's
resilient then what you need to do is
make sure those investors are investing
in businesses that take this seriously
and we see that if you take for example
on that West NatWest have shown the way
they've shown how by taking this issue
very seriously they can get investors in
uh on their side now you're talking in
particular to the National employee
savings trust Nest yes why are you going
with them first well when you think as
far as compulsory pension savings is
concerned most of the small businesses
in the country their employees end up
putting their cash into these uh into
nest and if Nest is not taking this
issue seriously and putting s very high
on the agenda then what we're seeing is
small businesses suffering instead of
being able to gain from that investment
what are you hoping that these
shareholders are going to do you're not
looking for them to disinvest for from
late players just wrap them over the
knuckles well we think ultimately it's
in their own interest to disinvest
because if a business is uh consistently
abusing its suppliers then ultimately
that will undermine that business and
they will find that they find it much
more difficult to get suppliers and the
suppliers they've got are likely to be
less resilient of course not every year
shareholder is investing solely on ESG
ground some of them might like the fact
that these companies are husbanding
their cash resources carefully well
that's a pretty short-sighted view
because ultimately most big businesses
are only as good as their suppliers and
the employees now if they don't take
that issue seriously they may get away
with it in the short term and
shareholders should think about that but
in the longer term that business is
under Threat all right Martin gotta
leave it there good to see you this
morning thank you
foreign
Friday nights declines on Wall Street
were followed by reverses overnight for
equities in the Asia Pacific region it's
the current picture all of the main
indices were lower apart from Sydney in
Australia and Europe equities have also
traded to the downside this morning
here's the current picture all of the
main Continental European indices in
negative territory right now talking
points this morning include the German
lab equipment maker Sartorius it Shares
are off by some 15 percent in Frankfurt
that follows a profits warning well here
in London the ftse 100 is also in
negative territory right now off a
quarter of one percent in a broad-based
sell-off in terms of features well ocado
and JD Sports are the biggest blue chip
fallers in percentage terms at the top
of the screen there you can see crota
the Specialty Chemicals group that's off
by one and a third percent right now
that is off uh due to broker comment
outside the ftse 100 the refurbished
consumer technology specialist music
magpie is ahead by some eight and a half
percent that's on an upbeat trading
statement well this is security systems
provider synectics is up by two and a
quarter percent for similar regions on
the foreign exchange markets well the
pound last week enjoyed its best weekly
gain since December last year to hit a
14-month high against the US dollar it's
given back a bit of those gains today
we're not very much as more or less
unchanged right now against the
Greenback and against the Euro not much
action in the FX markets I should say
Wall Street by the way is closed today
for a public holiday and I'm on the oil
price well that rallied on Friday today
it's given up some of those gains about
a Brent crude will currently set you
back
76.44 cents a barrel that's off a fifth
of one percent so joining me now is Will
hobbsey's Chief investment officer for
UK wealth management at Barclays well
good to see you this morning I mean it's
all about uh I guess uh the the bank of
England this week we had uh the FED last
week and the bank of Japan and the
European Central Bank over to the bank
of England this week
very much so Ian and I think you know
the point from us is that you know the
battle with inflation is not done yet uh
there are a few sort of geographies
where inflations legs are getting a bit
wobbly but it's nowhere near on the
canvas yeah but the problem for the UK
uh is that of all the economies
flighting inflation this looks like the
one that's still got most to do uh in
order to sort of finally uh put it on
the canvas so to speak are you expecting
a quarter point high court do you think
they could go the whole Hogan Race by
half a point
I'm not certainly the threat of the half
a point but we're still uh our uh our
forecast still say it's still two
quarter point forecasts left in this
cycle as you know the market is saying a
bit more than that I think you've got 90
bips priced in for the next three months
so maybe 130 beyond that uh the question
for markets in the context of you know
the coverage you guys have been doing so
well on the mortgage uh mortgage strains
uh is how much can they do uh our
suspicion is they won't quite get as far
as the market is suggesting at the
moment but that's certainly the threat
we've got to be aware that uh you know
the industry uh you know the various
central banks all forecasters they
haven't got a great record in
forecasting inflation that's not for
want of trying it just remains a you
know an unpredictable foe I think yeah
absolutely well I mean you mentioned the
mortgage rate so I think we've got
something like 400 000 people's fixed
rate deals rolling over but uh over this
month July and uh August I mean that's a
pretty high number by historic
comparisons isn't it
yes and and look you know this is
something that has to sap the strength
of the UK economy uh in the months going
forward as you guys have been pointing
out
um I mean that there are some sort of
mitigating factors here so what you will
find in Q3 is that some of those energy
bills will come down uh that should be a
little bit helpful the other point that
people have been making regularly is
that if you look at sort of uh you know
a uh the percentage of people actually
exposed to mortgages or have mortgages
uh households um as low than it was 10
20 years ago uh it's down to around
about 30 percent
um and there is significant overlap uh
in that 30 of households with those
households that still have some dry
powders squirrel away from the pandemic
and other kind of other factors that's
not uh uh you know to to minimize the uh
stress and strain of this on various
households but there are mitigating
factors we're still stopping short of
you know doomsday uh the concern I think
that we've all got to watch for is
there's some something non-linear in the
house housing market so far you
fantastic this is drifting low but not
that not anything kind of comparable
with other economies that have got
similar shaped mortgage burdens to uh to
to the UK the risk is that actually
people are starting to force to bring
their houses to Market at lower prices
and realize those uh those low prices
and creating something a little bit more
um uh uh more dangerous but that's not
the case at the moment but we are at a
very precarious moment and the central
bank is right in the middle of it
actually say well very precarious good
to talk to you Sarah thanks for joining
us
now we've talked a lot on this program
lately about how businesses are
harnessing generative AI to boost their
productivity but such technology can
also be used for nefarious reasons and
purposes there are concerns that
advances in generative AI will change
the way cyber criminals are targeting
victims with me now is Tom Gillis he's
Cisco's new Global head of cyber
security Tom welcome to you I mean how
does generative AI make it uh easier if
you like for the criminals yeah thanks
thanks for having me
um so it's a huge change in technology
and that we the industry have been using
AI for decades but all of a sudden AI
can process words
so computers can actually speak to us
right and so if you think about how most
cyber attacks start it almost always
starts with an email remember that
friendly International Prince that needs
to borrow your bank account remember
that guy right wonderful friendly fella
well it's very easy to spot those emails
because the obvious spelling mistakes
phonetical you know grammatical errors
generative AI makes that go away so
imagine getting an email and say hey Ian
great seeing you at the game on Saturday
I took some pictures of you and the kids
and you were at the game on Saturday so
those emails are going to be
indistinguishable from real emails
that's a very material and real threat
that we're facing today so how are
vendors of cyber security products
seeing this threat off the good news is
that the same tools the attackers are
using to make these threats more
realistic can also be applied to help us
defend and so so as I said we've been
using AI to analyze things like email
for decades and having the ability to to
process an order of magnitude more info
Nation allows us to figure out friend
from foe far more accurately than we
could in the past and so I believe that
we'll be able to stay a step ahead of
the attackers with these Technologies
what else are you doing with AI
there is an opportunity there's some
buzz in the industry about you know can
AI replace a security analyst and I
think we're realizing that that's
probably never going to be the case
especially in security because you
always have a human on the other end of
the wire that's trying to manipulate and
fool the computers but can AI be a very
very powerful assistant absolutely so
things as mundane as writing rules that
go into a firewall we think we can make
that 10 times more efficient you know
humans are still involved but we can
make the human technologists more
efficient with an AI assistant you've
been talking a lot about something
called xdr extended detection and
Remediation what does that mean in
practice for the underneath your
homework yes so so so as those emails
from that friendly prints become more
and more indistinguishable
we realized in the industry is that we
can't just look at email we can't just
look on the endpoint we can't just look
on the network we have to look across
all of them and so so the industry calls
it xdr extended detection or remediation
where you look across email web endpoint
and network and you correlate an
activity and be like wait a minute that
friendly fellow that says he saw you at
the game that's not a real email and
your machine is behaving badly and is
trying to access a customer database
right if we can lay these things out
side by side the attacks become much
more clear I mean the weird thing about
this is is taking human interaction out
of their students I mean certainly at
our company you know we're always told
to be on our God and look closely at
this it feels a simple future as though
the computers are going to be doing all
of that yeah well uh when you can talk
to a computer and Nick can now all of a
sudden talk back to you in a sensible
way it is going to transform everything
about how we interact with these systems
but also how these systems can be used
to spoof us in our day-to-day life yes
now you left Cisco in 2011 and you and
you came back this year what I mean
there's an old saying never go back why
have you well I left I left Cisco and I
had a vision around starting a new
company and their company
um was acquired by VMware and I stayed
at VMware for for five years I chose to
come back to Cisco this time because I
think there is a significant shift
happening in Industry where that xdr
thing you were asking me about is
representative of the need to look very
broadly across multiple different
domains and that drives a need for a
security platform and Cisco was
particularly well suited because we have
email web endpoint and network and we
can stitch all that together in a way to
make it easier for our customers to
digest and more effective at stopping
that friendly Prince